travel is once again picking up and this
summer people are ready to hit the road
and we are getting some tips and tricks
from travel expert janine tornatore
janine welcome to the show we are
seeing people traveling like crazy
they're ready to get out of town
and as we head out of the 4th of july
weekend and beyond what are some of your
top picks for summer travel
well look there you're right this is an
unprecedented summer in terms of how
many people are out there traveling
and as we head into the second half of
the summer there's so much opportunity
you know we do start to see demand
drop somewhat when we get into august so
if you're looking later in the summer
when the kids head back to school that's
a really great time but even
you know early to mid july um that's top
busy season so
let's start with a staycation for folks
who just want to stay local look
it's places like the cosmopolitan i
think that really do it right for those
local staycations
they have the residential style
suite so you really kind of get that
getaway feeling with those private
terraces so looking for those types of
properties if you're doing a staycation
something where it's a little bit beyond
just the standard hotel
room but look if you want to get away
for a beach vacation
san diego i think is one of the best
picks for a drive getaway a five-hour
drive from las vegas
um you know and here's why i like san
diego this summer san diego is actually
a big convention town so there is a lot
of hotel inventory which means it's
keeping prices reasonable
and there's still a lot of availability
even in places like i love the westin
in the gaslamp quarter my family loves
this one because they have corn hole
they have table tennis on their sun deck
so lots of fun games to play a rooftop
pool so you kind of have that respite
from any crowds
but certainly you know san diego would
be my pick for a drive getaway
now if you're looking to fly somewhere
nashville nashville has been a hot
destination for a while but i love it in
the summer because i think you get the
best of both worlds you get that
fun downtown nashville vibe with all the
music
you have the ryman you have so many
great things to do in the city but it's
also a great
base point for launching off into the
smoky mountains so you can get that
outdoor escape and hit some of those
wonderful destinations
the renaissance would be my pick for a
hotel you're right downtown in the heart
of the city you have a great
um bar restaurant scene right there
within your hotel
and lots of availability for this summer
as well and you're saying
if you really want to do a bucket list
place canada
is the place to be huh well look canada
is really not completely open yet but
where everybody i think you know that
really likes to head north to get kind
of that cooler weather is looking
forward to that so places like montreal
and toronto i say keep those on your
list and keep an eye out
for when those do reopen we're also
seeing that a lot of people are really
looking forward to
getting back to places like europe um
and people are already heading back
there this summer in fact marriott data
shows that
places like uh london paris rome munich
and madrid are really
kind of the hot places people are
looking to right now so
the good news for those international
travelers is that it is doable at this
point we love that you have so much
great information janine thank you so
much happy travels to you and jc
over to you